transfer was the last night extended
superbowl let's watch this [ __ ] TV
spots you want to know why they keep
coming here where are the others ones
you're hiding friends I don't sell out
your world is dying God they'll know
miss Bryant
Wow a secretive
moneymaker my maker Bobby's gonna die I
know that upsets people when I say
things like that he's gonna die that's
almost the same exact trailer I mean
that line for Mark Wahlberg it was a was
a new line that we got there's a couple
of things that looked a little different
here that what I saw from the last one
it looked like a Dinobot was getting
killed at around 17 seconds nice I hope
they're actually used in this one that
would be cool I think what people are
gonna be tripping balls about though is
when he says my maker his maker is a
woman which would make sense most human
beings are either pushed out of a vagina
or sea sectioned out of a woman's
stomach so I wouldn't mind it if Optimus
Prime's maker was female that actually
makes me intrigued we're on a serious
note that actually gives me really
intrigued that makes me go I want to
know who this maker is who's causing him
to be all [ __ ] you know attack
bumblebee then kill bumblebee I know
he's everyone's favorite and they're all
I go he's gonna get a spin-off movie
[ __ ] that bumblebee deserves to die it
would make the franchise a lot more
interesting and I might actually give a
[ __ ] about a robot in one of these films
and I bet there's like something else I
miss I'm not a big transformers
enthusiast what John and I are planning
on doing is doing one of those movie
commentary watch along things where we
watch the original cartoon together so I
could finally see that thing and see it
well if I can get things like some in
nostalgia and still the me to give more
[ __ ] about when these shitty films come
out but who knows michael banck fifth
time is sometimes a charm
alright guys subscriber the real rejects
follow me on instagram and twitter at
the greg alba and shout out to Shia
LaBeouf heard you got arrested again
yeah